GOOD AFTERNOON THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
CALLED TO ORDER.
ALL THAT SECRETARY WITH YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR QUORUM.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT SO WE'RE
GONNA START THE COMMITTEE UNDER.
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE I SEE SENATOR
BILL IS READY TO PRESENT
[inaudible]
SENATOR.
SO YOU HAVE TWO ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA -- STARTED -- TO ELEVEN
LIKE [inaudible]
THERE YEAH [inaudible]
GOT -- MISTER CHAIRMAN
CALIFORNIA HAS MAE IT CLEAR THE
DRESSING HOMELESSNESS IS A TOP
PRIORITY.
AND EVERY ONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES
IS LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS.
AND CURRENTLY CALTRANS HAS AND
FORTY IN A HANDFUL JURISDICTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO LEASE
PROPERTY FOR HOMELESS SHELTER
PROGRAMS AT BELOW MARKET RATE.
NOW THIS IS ALREADY GIVES THE
CITIES.
AND COUNTIES -- HELPFUL TOOL TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S SIGNIFICANT
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
THE REALITY IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
CAMPING AND SLEEPING IN THESE
PROPERTIES ALREADY BASICALLY.
AND AS WE KNOW CALTRANS SPENDS.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EACH YEAR
CLEANING UP OUR CAMPS.
I LIKE TO POINT OUT LIKE IN MY
COUNTY THEY SPENT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE YEAR.
JUST CLEANING UP.
YOU KNOW SO IT DOES COST THE
STATE MONEY.
AND THE CITIES AND COUNTIES NEED
TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER WITH CAL
TRANS COMING UP WITH REAL
SOLUTIONS TO CONNECT PEOPLE WITH
HOUSING.
AND SERVICES AND LAST YEAR WE
PASSED.
THE SB.
FIVE ONE NINE THIS ALLOWED THE
STORY IN LOS ANGELES AND SAN
JOSE.
THEY HAVE TAKEN AND THEY HAVE
TAKEN ADVANTAGES ARE WORKING ON
SEVERAL PROJECTS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES TO MEET.
IMMEDIATE AND PRESSING NEEDS FOR
SHELTER AND SERVICES.
THE TIME IS NOW TO EXTEND THE
SOLUTION STATEWIDE.
SO THE OTHER CITIES AND COUNTIES.
MAY HAVE THE OPTION. FOR THEIR
COMMITTEES AT THEIR REQUEST.
SO THE BILL WOULD ALLOW CALTRANS
THE WRIT LEAST REAL REAL
PROPERTY TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
STATEWIDE. FOR THE PURPOSES
STATUS AND EMERGENCY SHELTER
FEEDING PROGRAMS FOR DOLLAR
MONTH.
ALSO CAPS ADMINISTRATIVE FEES.
AND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
PROTECTS EXISTING AUTHORITY
BASED ON PASS LEGISLATION.
WE WANT TO CITIES ALREADY DOING
THIS TO AVOID NEW ADMINISTRATIVE
HURDLES.
WE HAVE SOME WITNESSES CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME ME
REPRESENT PLEASE -- MISTER CHAIR
JOE CRUISE ON BEHALF THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE.
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR -- THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN HOMES THIS IS A
CRISIS IN SAN JOSE IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE.
THERE ARE PROXY SIXTY ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES IN SAN
JOSE ANY GIVEN NIGHT.
AS PART OF THE SOLUTION OR CITY
COUNCIL APPROVED TWO SITES THE
PILOT WILL BE CALLED THE BRIDGE
HOUSING COMMUNITIES.
THESE COMMUNITIES PROVIDE IN
FROM TINY HOMES IN A SAFE
PRIVATE AND SECURE ENVIRONMENT.
THE SITE WILL SERVE ONE HUNDRED
PEOPLE PER YEAR AS PART OF OUR
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO TRANSITION
PEOPLE TO PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
LAST YEAR TO SENATOR.
CENTER BELL AUTHORED SB FIVE
NINETEEN WHICH ALLOWS THE CITY
TO LEASE LAND FROM CALTRANS FOR
ONE DOLLAR A MONTH.
SB TWO ELEVEN BUILDS ON THE
SUCCESS IN WILL RIDE THE SAME
ARRANGEMENT THE SAN JOSE HAS TO
OTHER CITIES AND COUNTIES
STATEWIDE. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECT THE OR DRIVE A THANK YOU.
SIX WITH THIS PLEASE TAKE NEWMAN
WHO REPRESENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS EMILY HOW
CAN ON THE HOMELESS SERVICES
MANAGER WITH THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK OUT IN OUR STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB.
TWO ELEVEN AS A SAN JOSE MANY
CITIES INCLUDING SACRAMENTO ARE
FACING AT I'M AT CRISIS OF AND
SHELTERED HOMELESSNESS AND WE TO
HAVE BEEN.
ADDRESSING THE IMPACTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE KNOW THAT THE
ONLY SOLUTION IS HOUSING BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THE CITY WE HAVE TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE CRISIS ON THE
STREETS AND WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE -- WRAPAROUND
SERVICES IN A SHELTERING SETTING
WE KNOW THIS WORKS WE RECENTLY
OPENED A WRAPAROUND RE HOUSING
SHELTER UP IN NORTH SACRAMENTO
IN A OUR HOUSE THAT WE WERE
LEASING.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO BRING
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS TO OVER
SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE EVER
SEVENTEEN MONTHS WE SAW 40% OF
THEM RE HOUSE AND 80%
RECONNECTED TO MEDICAL SERVICES.
HOWEVER THE COST OF THE FACILITY
WAS ASTRONOMICAL OLD OVER 40% OF
OURS SERVICE BUDGET WENT JUST A
PAIN THE LEASE AND MAINTENANCE
OF THIS BUILDING.
WE HAVE PLANS TO DO ADDITIONAL
SITES AND WORKING RIGHT NOW WITH
CALTRANS ON A SITE NOT TOO FAR
FROM HERE UNDER THE W. X.
FREEWAY.
AND IF WE ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
SITE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
CALTRANS WE'LL BE ABLE TO DIVERT
FUNDS THAT WE USED TO HAVE TO
USE FOR THE FACILITIES TO
PROVIDE REACHED RICHER SERVICES
AND RE HOUSING AND WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY --
SO WE ALSO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB TWO ELEVEN WE
ARE -- WE ARE ANXIOUS TO HAVE
THE PARTNERSHIP WITH CALTRANS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO STARTING OUR
WORK ON STANDING UP TO NEW
SHELTER AND PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THE WHAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL PLEASE TAKE YOUR
NAME AND YOU REPRESENT PLEASE --
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND SPORT CUTE.
STEVE ALL COMBAT THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
AND SUPPORT.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION -- HAVE SHARE
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS BILL.
COMING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS THE OF THE AUTHOR OF
THE COMMITTEE MISTER MISTER
CHAIR I THINK IT'S A GREAT BILL
AND WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM ALL
MAKE A MOTION TO SUPPORT IT.
HER APPRECIATE THAT.
SIR WOULD YOU -- LIKE TO CLOSE.
AT THE PROPER TIME I SUPPORT THE
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FOR YOUR CONSIDERING.
THANK YOU -- CENTER THIS AN
ISSUE I'D LIKE TO SEE RESOLVED.
FINALLY -- SO WE CAN STOP OF THE
ONE OFF THREE CITY IN CALIFORNIA.
THE DOCTOR POLICIES STATEWIDE.
I UNDERSTAND THE GOVERNOR HAS
HIS OWN IDEA HOW THEY SHOULD BE
DONE.
THAT YOU WILL BE WORKING WITH
HIM -- TO TO A COMPROMISE BEFORE
SENDING THIS BILL HIS WAY CITIES --
WITHOUT ALSO FOR YOUR BILL TODAY
AND CALL THE ROLL IN WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF MEMBERS
AND I THINK WE WANT.
TO THREE WE'RE SHORT ONE STILL
SERVICE LIKE TO SHOW -- START
YOUR THE BILL -- AS OF THE TWO
TWO SEVEN SEVEN MISTER CHARLIE
HAVE FOR YOURSELF AND MIGHT
MYSELF WE ARE INTRODUCING US BE.
TO SEVENTY SEVEN AND I WOULD
LIKE TO FIRST THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US AND CRAFTING THIS BILL -- THE
STAFF WORKED A LONG TIME -- FOR
MANY HOURS IS GREEN A RECENT
AGREEING WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE HARD
WORK.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
TRANSPORTATION ANALYSTS WERE.
PUTTING THIS BILL TOGETHER --
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL PROVIDES CLARIFICATION
AND DIRECTION TO THE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
AS WE KNOW SB ONE PROVIDED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION TO THE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM TO FIND EACH
ELIGIBLE ENTITY AS IT AND THAT
IS PASSED THE TRANSPORTATION
SALES TAX MATTER.
OR DEVELOPER FEAR OTHER KINDS OF
INCOME.
THIS TOTALS -- ONE BILLION
DOLLARS EVERY FIVE YEARS TO
LOCAL AGENCIES FOR
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS TO SEE
TO SEE AS A SERVER THAT THERE
HAS BEEN INTERPRETATION ISSUES.
AS AS TO HOW THIS SHOULD BE
ADMINISTERED SHORTLY AFTER SB
ONE WAS ENACTED -- THE CHAIRS --
MYSELF AND YOU IN AND MISTER ARE
FRAZIER CHAIR FRAZIER HAD
SUBMITTED A LETTER. TO THE C. T.
C. REQUESTING TO SEE TO SEE
ADMINISTERED.
LOCAL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
SIMILAR TO HOW.
THE PROGRAM IS ADMINISTERED OR
PROP ONE BEAT.
WHICH PRIMARILY INVOLVED A
FORMULA.
UNDER SB ONE AT FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING CYCLES -- CTC
HOWEVER THE STATUS A 50%
COMPETITIVE AND A 50% -- PROGRAM --
ON THE FORMULA.
IS ALSO UNDERSTANDING THE CDC
WOULD REVISIT THIS BATTER ONCE A
YEAR.
ONCE INITIAL FUNDING CYCLES HAVE
BEEN CARRIED OUT.
UNFORTUNATELY I INTRODUCED THIS
BILL BECAUSE HE TO SEE DID NOT
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THAT ACTION --
SB WHAT WELL TO SEVENTY SEVEN
NOW PROVIDES AS A REMEDY OF FOR
ANY INTERPRETATION ISSUES
ASSERTED BY THE CDC THE BILL
PROVIDE.
CLARITY AND DIRECTION THE BILL
HAS BEEN NEGOTIATED AGREED UPON.
BY THE SELF HELP COUNTIES
COALITION.
LASTLY THE BILL PRESERVES THE
INTEGRITY OF SB.
ONE THANK YOU AND REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.%
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
STOP WE'VE GOT A QUORUM AND I'D
LIKE TO HAVE MEANT CERTAIN
CULTURAL PLEASE [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I FONG.
FONG HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
HERE BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
CLICK HERE.
TO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM HERE DAILY
DALY HERE DEEP.
A PAIR FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON HERE MEDINA [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
IT IS.
EIGHT IT IS EIGHT WILL A LEAD
ROLE COULD PERHAPS A MEMBERS ON
THAT'S OUR LOCAL -- IN HER
MYSELF SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO JUST
IF YOU BEAR WITH ME -- MISTER
BELL -- COUPLE HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS.
OF FILE ITEM NINE SB SIX FORTY
EIGHT CHIANG IS AS SIMPLE BY THE
AUTHOR -- MEASURES I CONSENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE ACR. NINETY
SEVEN PATTERSON FILE ITEM SIX SB --
THREE FIFTY EIGHT FROM SORT OF
TRANSPORTATION -- FILE AND TEN
SB SIX FIFTY SIX HUESO.
AND FILE I'M TWELVE S. C. R.
ELEVEN CHIANG THOSE ARE ON BUT
IT'S NOT CONSENT I WOULD
ENTERTAIN.
I'VE -- MISTER GIBSON SECOND I
MISSED FONG -- THEM SEPARATE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER FIVE FONG.
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
I BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
THEY LOW IQ [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
ENDING HAM AYE DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON R. GIPSON I'D GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
IT'S A KILLER IS I WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OF THE PREP SO MEMBERS --
THANK YOU CENTER BILL FOR YOUR
PATIENTS WHO YOU'RE WITH THE
SCHOOL -- PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
IN THE REPRESENT PLACER THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
KEEP DONE EXACTED RECORD THIS
AWFUL COUNTIES COALITION IS --
SIR BILL MENTIONED IN HIS
OPENING THE STATE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM IS A FUNDING
SOURCE THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
ORIGINALLY IN PROP ONE BE LATER
IN THE SP.
ONE AUTHORIZATION TO REWARD
LOCAL COUNTIES THAT HAVE GONE
OUT AND TAX THEMSELVES TO
ENHANCE THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE.
THESE COUNTIES HAVE EXPANSION
PLANS THAN EVER HAVE OVERSIGHT
OF NOT ONLY THE BOARDS OF THE
ELECTED OF THE THE THE
TRANSPORTATION SEES BUT ALSO OF
THE PUBLIC -- THEY HAVE A MOTTO
IS SELF OF COUNTIES IS PROMISES
MADE PROMISES KEPT IS BECAUSE
THE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT THEY SEE.
IN DELIVERING THOSE PROJECTS IN
THE TRUST THAT THEY HAVE IN THE
DIRECT RELATIONSHIPS THAT THEY
HAVE WITH THE VOTERS.
THIS PROGRAM -- THE STATE LOCAL
PARTIAL PROGRAM AGAIN WAS
ESTABLISHED TO REWARD THOSE OF
GOING OUT TO THE VOTERS AND
ESTABLISH THAT TRUST.
THIS FUNDING PACKAGE THAT YOU'RE
CONTEMPLATING TODAY AND THE THE
OVERSIGHT THAT THAT IS BEING
APPLIED TO IT IT REALLY HAS BEEN
A NEGOTIATED PROCESS THE SUFFOLK
COUNTIES CAME TO A POSITION THAT
WITH THE CDC AND MADE THAT
RECOMMENDATION SENATOR BELL AND
GERMAN FRAZIER.
I THINK IN RECOGNITION OF THAT
COOPERATION -- AMENDED YOUR BILL
SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN TO REFLECT
THE CHANGES THAT HAD BEEN
NEGOTIATED WITH THE C. T. C.
FROM THE SELF OF COUNTIES AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH -- THE
POSITION OF THE ORGANIZATION --
HAS BEEN DEVELOPED OVER TIME AND
WORKING WITH OUR MEMBERSHIP --
AND I THINK IT'S ONE THAT IS NOT
ONLY FAIR -- TO COUNTIES WITH
MULTIPLE MADE IT MEASURES BUT
ALSO TO THE SMALLER COUNTIES --
WITH THAT WE APPRECIATE ALL THE
HARD WORK THAT YOU'VE PUT IN I
KNOW THAT YOU PUT IN A LETTER
DIRECTING THE CTC -- ALMOST TWO
YEARS AGO TO THE DAY TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WE ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR
FOLLOW UP IN INTRODUCING SB TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE WILL OF THE LEGISLATURE
NOTABLY THE VOTERS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS FOLLOWED.
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS APPRECIATE AND ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
HELLO MY NAME'S DEBBIE HAIL AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY FOR
MONTEREY COUNTY -- WERE IN USE
ALSO COUNTY AS OF NOVEMBER
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND ONE OF THE
KEY SELLING POINTS FOR US WAS TO
SAY THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO SECURE
STATE MATCHING FUNDS OF WE GOT
OUR OWN MEASURE.
ON SB ONE WAS A REAL GREAT GAME
CHANGER IN THAT REGARD AND WE
THINK OF COURSE SENATOR BELL --
CARE FRAZIER AND THE WHOLE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR SUPPORT
THAT MEASURE.
ON THE LOCAL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
IS ONE PROGRAM THAT GUARANTEES
THAT WE WILL GET THESE MATCHING
FUNDS -- MODERATE COUNTY
RECEIVES ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND UNDER THE CURRENT
FORMULA PER YEAR -- BUT IN THE
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM WE GOT A
GRANT FROM NINETEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR IMPORTANCE OF
REGIONAL BY WAY.
AND IT WOULD HAVE TAKEN US OVER
TWENTY YEARS TO GET THAT MONEY
SO -- IF IF THE PROGRAM WERE A
100% COMPETITIVE SO AS A RESULT
WE'RE VERY INTERESTED IN HAVING
SOME KIND OF POT FOR OF
COMPETITION ESPECIALLY FOR THE
SMALL COUNTIES -- WE DO FEEL
LIKE THAT EVERYONE USES THE
RESIN THE SMALL COUNTY WHETHER
IT'S TO GET TO THE BEACHES IN
MONTEREY OR WHETHER TO HAVE YOUR
FRESH US STORIES AND VEGETABLES
TRACKED UP TO YOUR SALAD BARS --
MANY OF THE CASE WILL COUNTIES
INCLUDING OURS ORIGINALLY
SUPPORTED -- THE CURRENT PROGRAM
OF 50% FOR NO OFFENSE AND 50%
COMPETITIVE SO THAT WE WOULD
HAVE ENOUGH OF A COMPETITIVE
FORMULA -- BUT WE HAD A REALLY
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSION AMONG ALL
THE SELF HELP COUNTIES.
AND WE ARRIVED AT THE COMPROMISE
PROPOSAL THAT IS CURRENTLY IN SB --
TWO SEVEN SEVEN AS IT STANDS NOW
THAT IT PROVIDES A MORE
PREDICTABLE FUNDING SURE FOR THE
BIG COUNTIES AND THE SMALL
COUNTIES.
BUT IT ALSO GIVES US A CHANCE TO
DO REALLY MEANINGFUL PROJECT
EVERY SO OFTEN OUT OF THIS
COMPETITIVE SHARE -- SAYS RESULT
THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY FOR
MONTEREY COUNTY SUPPORTS THIS
COMPROMISE MEASURE INTO --
SEVENTY SEVEN THERE IS ONE MINOR
ISSUE THAT STILL OUTSTANDING --
IT THAT -- THE DEVELOPER FEE
ENTITIES EVEN IF THEY'RE IN A
BIG SELF HELP COUNTY CAN STILL
COMPETE FOR THE COMPETITIVE
FUNDING THE WAY THAT THE
LANGUAGE IS CURRENTLY WORDED.
AND WE HOPE THAT AS IS MEASURE
MOVES ALONG THAT THERE WOULD BE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RECONSIDER
THAT -- IF YOU'RE COUNTY GETS A
LOT OF FORMULA MONEY UNDER THIS
PROGRAM -- THAT IT.
IS NOT QUITE THE SPIRIT OF WHAT
THE COMPROMISE PROPOSAL WAS WAS
THAT -- SMALL COUNTIES OR
COUNTIES WITH OURS -- THE SALES
TAXES -- BUT HAD DEVELOPER FEES
WOULD BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE.
BUT WITHOUT THAT CHANGE -- AND
CURRENTLY WITH THE ABILITY TO
SAVE UP TO FORMALLY FUNDS OVER
FIVE YEARS WHICH IS REALLY
VALUABLE TO US -- WE'RE
SUPPORTER OF IT SB TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
TELLING THE HUNTER ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND THE
SAN BENITO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARC WATTS
ON BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION TODAY
IN SUPPORT AND I HOPE REPORT
LATER THIS WEEK -- TO OTHER
COUNTIES WILL BE COMING ON BOARD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBERTS AND I'LL BE AT THE
CENTER COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT
IN THE CENTER CEMETERY COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WE
DON'T YET HAVE A POSITION BUT WE
DO APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK YOUR
CELLPHONE COUNTIES COALITION WE
HOPE TO BE BACK.
VERY SOON WITH SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIRK BLACKBURN --
HAVE THE SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS SENDAK AND
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE TOP ON
BEHALF ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ENTRY ENTRY
ON BEHALF OF THE FRESNO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY OUR
BORDERS YOU HAVE TO MEET SINCE
THE MEMBERS OF COMMON FRIENDS.
OF BUT STASHED RECOMMENDING A
SUPPORT AND WE THINK OF THE
SOCIAL COUNTIES COALITION FOR
CREATE A FORM FOR US TO GO
THROUGH.
MANY ITERATIONS OF FORMULA AND
DIFFERENT APPROACHES ON THIS --
GOOD WORK GOOD FORM FOR THAT WE
THANK BOTH CHAIRS FOR WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DISCUSSES WAS BECAUSE SUPPORT --
ANYBODY IN THE OFFICE IN THE
AUDIENCE OF LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR SHARE CONCERNS
WITH AUTHORS BILL PLEASE TAKE
STEP UP THE MIKE IN A STATE YOUR
NAME IN HERE REPRESENTING PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BRISCO
SCORED WE HAVE TO SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENT
STANISLAUS COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS.
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION.
THE THE POSITION WAS TAKEN PRIOR
TO THE BILL BEING RECENTLY
AMENDED AS WELL SO IT'S A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION -- WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT THE AUTHOR AND YOU
MISTER CHAIR -- DID ON BRING IN
SB ONE TO FRUITION VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP
EXHIBIT BIKE SECTOR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR DONE AND THE SELF HELP
COUNTIES COALITION IN GENERAL --
END RESTATING WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT WAS -- YOU
KNOW AS AS SOMEONE THAT
REPRESENTS SEVERAL NPOS THEY
HAVE SALES TAX MEASURES WE
APPRECIATE THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
THAT.
A DISCOUNT IS WORK REALLY HARD
TO TAX THEMSELVES IN ORDER TO
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO STATE
ASSETS AND HAVING SOME
PREDICTABILITY.
IS REALLY KEY IN HELPING THEM TO
TO PLAN.
I WILL SAY THOUGH THAT -- THE
WAY THAT THIS IS PLAYED OUT IS
ACTUALLY BEEN QUITE INTERESTING
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT CYCLE --
ONE FOR ALL OF THE VARIOUS -- SP
ONE PROGRAM SOLUTIONS FOR
CONGESTED CORRIDORS TRADE
CORRIDORS.
AND LOCAL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
SEVERAL OF OF THOSE PROJECTS
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE
FULLY FUNDED.
IF THE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
DID NOT HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
SO AND SO -- THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL TAKES APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY OUT OF THE COMPETITIVE
PROGRAM.
IN A CONVERTED OVER TO FORMULATE
SHARE -- UNDER THE GUIDELINE
PROCESS ALSO FIRST FIRING
COUNTIES THAT SEEK TO HAVE A
SALES TAX MEASURE.
THAT TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR POT
IS ELIMINATED AND I BELIEVE SO
IS THE ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR GUARANTEE FOR SMALLER --
JURISDICTIONS AND SO -- VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
CONTINUE YOU -- A DISCUSSION ON
THIS ISSUE BUT FOR US IT'S
REALLY ABOUT PROJECT DELIVERY
SEVERAL OF THESE COUNTIES.
THEY DON'T GENERATE VERY MUCH
PER YEAR AND SO WE REALLY DO
NEED THE STATE TO BE A PARTNER
TO HELP US -- FULLY FUND ARE
PROJECTS AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
AUTHOR ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
IF YOU. FIFTY ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC LIKE TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AUTHORS BILL
FOR SURE CONCERNS.
SEEM NINE WHICH IS THE COMMITTEE
OF THE AUTHOR THIS COMMAND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
CENTER BILL.
I HAD A QUESTION FOR MAYBE THE
AUTHOR OR ONE OF THE WITNESSES --
I BELIEVE THE WITNESS FROM
MONTEREY MENTIONED THAT IT'S
POSSIBLE UNDER THE LANGUAGE OF
THIS AMENDED BILL THAT LARGER
COUNTIES COULD STILL COMPETE.
FOR SOME OF THE FUNDING THAT WAS
SET ASIDE FOR SMALLER COUNTIES --
THROUGH THE DEVELOPER FEES
PORTION DO IT IF I UNDERSTOOD
THAT CORRECTLY CAN YOU CLARIFY
THAT -- EITHER WITNESS.
THAT'S WHEN YOU'RE STANDING WITH
THE BILL'S WRITTEN.
THE COUNTIES THIS IS THROUGH THE
CHAIR WITH YOUR PERMISSION AND
THE COUNTIES THEMSELVES WOULD
NOT BE COMPETING THERE'S A
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS FOR
DEVELOPERS TO COMPETE IN CERTAIN
JURISDICTIONS.
I THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
AMBIGUITY AND QUESTION OF
WHETHER OR NOT.
DEVELOPERS IN OTHER COUNTIES
WOULD BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE SAN
LUIS OBISPO IS NOT A CELLPHONE
COUNTY SO YOU'RE COUNTY WOULD
NOT PARTICIPATE IN ANY OF THE
PROGRAMS BUT IF YOU HAD A
DEVELOPER.
THAT QUALIFIED UNDER THIS
PROGRAM THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
COMPETE BECAUSE YOU'RE UNDER THE
POPULATION CAP -- WITHOUT
QUESTION SO WHETHER NOT LARGER
COUNTIES WILL HAVE TO GO BACK
AND CLARIFY THAT LANGUAGE STAFF.
IN ONE OF THE THINGS OLD OLD
SHARE WITH YOU IS I I COME FROM
A FEE AND FINANCE AUTHORITY THAT
DOES USED TO DEVELOPER
MITIGATION FEES.
I I THINK IT'S LIKE NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND CHANGE PER
HOME THE GOES TO TRANSPORTATION
ISSUES -- AND SO THEY USE THAT
AS A LEVERAGE POINT WITH MET
CELLS TAX MEASURES ALSO AND ALSO
STATE FUNDING.
SO WHEN THEY WHEN THEY BUNDLE
ALL OF THESE THEY ACTUALLY HAVE.
A A LEVERAGE POINT.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS IS WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING IS.
THAT -- COUNTIES THAT DO HAVE --
SECTIONS OTHER COUNTY OR
WHATEVER THAT HAVE MITIGATION
FEES -- THAT THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE BECAUSE
IT AGAIN.
THEY ARE STEPPING UP ABOVE AND
BEYOND THEIR SALES TAX MEASURE
ALSO.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
UP.
I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY WHAT TO DO
TODAY WITH RESPECT TO VOTING
BOTH SLOW COG TENS OBISPO AND SB
COG SANTA BARBARA MY THE TWO
COUNTIES ARE REPRESENT.
HAD OPPOSITION LETTERS IT SOUNDS
LIKE FROM.
THE EARLIER WITNESSES TESTIMONY
THAT THERE THAT MAY HAVE BEEN --
PRIOR TO THE MOST RECENT AMENDED
VERSION SO -- ALTHOUGH I WILL
PROBABLY HAVE STAND TODAY BUT
HOPEFULLY -- IN GENERAL WE CAN
WORK ON TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THERE IS SOME PRESERVE MONEY FOR
SMALLER COUNTIES BECAUSE AS THE
WITNESS MENTIONED.
AND MILLIONS AND MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF CARS TRAVERSE
HIGHWAY ONE A ONE AND FORTY SIX
AND FORTY ONE TO SHIP PRODUCE
SYNC IT TO BEACHES AND THIS AND
THAT.
AND OFTEN IT IN AND SEND OUR IS
ITSELF OF COUNTY BY THE WAY.
A ST LOUIS IS NOT BUT OFTEN THEY
ARE.
WHEN YOU MOVED TO STRICTLY
FORMULAIC COLLOCATION IT COULD
BE PROBLEMATIC FOR COUNTIES?
I WOULD JUST OFFER THAT THE THE
CELL SMALL COUNTIES ARE INCLUDED
IN THE PROGRAM FUNDING AND
THEY'RE GUARANTEED A FUNDING AND
THEN THE COMPETITIVE FUNDING AS
OUTLINED IN SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
IS SPECIFICALLY.
FOR COUNTIES UNDER SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND WHICH MAKE UP
ABOUT 11% OF THE POPULATION OF
SELF HELP COUNTIES AND THEY'VE
BEEN ALLOCATED 15% OF THE
FUNDING SO.
THE THE ORGANIZATION I I WILL
AND I KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU
DELIVERY -- EXTENSIVELY WITHIN
YOUR CAUCUSES I WILL TELL YOU
THAT FOR YEARS TWO YEARS THIS
ORGANIZATION DELIBERATED AND
TRIED TO WORK AND COME UP WITH
FORMULAS THAT.
NOT ONLY TOOK CARE OF THOSE THAT
HAVE LESS BUT ALSO RECOGNIZE
THOSE THAT HAVE DONE MORE
INCLUDING GOING TO THEIR VOTERS
MULTIPLE TIMES. TO GET APPROVAL
SO AGAIN THIS WAS A PAINFUL
PROCESS FOR THIS ORGANIZATION
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT.
THE RESULT I BELIEVE IT'S ONLY
FAIR TO THE SMALL COUNTIES BUT
ALSO -- RECOGNIZES THOSE THAT
HAVE DONE MORE BY GOING BACK TO
THEIR VOTERS TO SEEK ADDITIONAL
APPROVALS TO INVEST IN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE SPLIT BETWEEN -- LARGE
COUNTIES AND SMALL COUNTIES
SMALL COUNTIES HAVE A SEPARATE
OUGHT. 15%.
THE REMAINDER GOES TO THE OVER.
AND A SMALL COUNTIES ABOUT. 7%
ABOUT 11% POPULATION THERE STILL
INCLUDED IN THE GROWING EXTRA
15% SO IT'S KIND OF THE
COMPROMISE OF HE WANTS IT THAT
WAY [inaudible]
COMPROMISES.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR
[inaudible]
MR BIGELOW.
I I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS --
MISSED ABOUT.
THIS IS REALLY A WE BOTH WORKED
ON THIS IS COUNTY SUPERVISORS IN
THE PAST.
IT IS A LITTLE BIT CHALLENGING
THOUGH FROM TIME TO TIME WHILE
MAKING UP 11% OF THE POPULATION
IT REALLY.
ISN'T THE REAL THRUSTING ISSUE
THE THRUSTING ISSUES AMOUNT OF
MILES THE SERVER AND WITH THE
PREVIOUS FORMULA THE PREVIOUS
FORMING A KIND OF GAVE A LITTLE
ADDED VALUE TO THOSE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES. TO MANAGE
THEMSELVES IN A BETTER WAY --
MAYBE YOU COULD ADDRESS HOW HOW
YOU HOW YOU.
YOU SAW COMING TO THIS SOLUTION
SO I CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND THAT
BECAUSE I HAVE A ONE OF THE
COUNTIES THAT'S GOT IN
OPPOSITION.
I'M TORN BETWEEN THIS WHOLE
SCENARIO I KIND OF LIKE YOUR
IDEA AND I I'M TORN WITH THE THE
FOLKS WHO ARE OPPOSING IT SO.
HELP ME TO UNDERSTAND THE
MILEAGE IS LIKE A TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND TWO OR MILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR ACCOUNT OUT OF THE
I WOULD SAY.
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FIVE POINT.
TWO BILLION FROM SB. ONE OKAY SO --
IF YOU LOOK AT THAT WAY --
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE FORMULA FOR
SP -- ONE BENEFIT ONE GROUP FOR
THE OTHER GROUP THIS THIS
FORMULA SLIGHTLY BENEFITS OF
SMALLER COUNTIES BECAUSE OF THE
INFILL EMPHASIS ON THE FACT THAT --
WE'RE WE'RE BASING IT ON THE
WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS FUNDS TO
BASE IT ON THE THE FACT THAT
THEY PASSED THE OF SALES TAX SO
WE BASE SOME OF IT ON REVENUE
AND ON POPULATION.
SO -- IT'S FOR THIS ONE SUB
ACCOUNT IT'S BASED ON THAT KIND
OF FORMULA AS A COMPROMISE OTHER
OTHER FORMULAS.
BENEFIT.
COUNTIES THAT ARE LARGELY MILES
LIKE THE GAS TAX FORMULA COURSE
DOES.
AND LIKE URBAN COUNTIES GET LESS.
BASED ON POPULATION PER CAPITA.
THEN SOME SMALL COUNTIES WITH
LARGE LANE MILES SO IT'S KIND OF
I WOULD LOOK AT IT LIKE THAT IS
PART OF THE IT'S ONE SUBGROUP.
SO WE TRY TO TREAT THEM FAIRLY
AND THAT'S KIND OF WHAT THE
COMPROMISE I THINK THEY WORKED
OUT AND WE WE HAVE A SIZE THEY
WORKED IT OUT THEY WORKED IT OUT
THEY WERE THE ONES THAT CAME UP
WITH THE SCARBOROUGH.
SO THE FINAL QUESTION IS YEAH
YOU DON'T SEE AN ISSUE WITH THE
THE ISSUE OF COMPOUNDING THE THE
REVENUES FOR THE LOCAL SO WHEN
THEY HAVE YOU HAVE A MAJOR
SUBDIVISION.
THAT'S CREATED AND THEY DO HAVE
AS AN EXAMPLE THE NINETEEN
THOUSAND THAT WAS UTILIZED.
YOU AT THAT NUMBER WITH THE THE
LOCAL MATCH FROM THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY.
YOU COULD ACTUALLY SEE A LARGER
CHUNK OF THAT.
I THINK HERE YOU KNOW ON THE
ACCOUNT MAYBE NOT AND DRAW DOWN
ON IT MORE THAN.
THEN THE OTHERS COULD EVER GET.
TO I THINK MOST OF THE FORMULAS
BASED ON POPULATION AND PART OF
PART OF ITS BASED ON THE REVENUE
FROM THE SALES TAX OR DEVELOPER
FEES SO.
IF YOU WANT TO SAY IT'S SKEWED
TOWARDS POPULATION.
AMONG THE SMALL COUNTY GROUP.
OKAY SO YOU KIND OF YOU KIND OF
GOT A LOOK AT THE THE FORMULA
THE WEIGHTS WORK IT WAS A
COMPROMISE EVERYBODY AGREED.
TO RATHER MOST PEOPLE AGREE.
TO YEAH I WAS JUST LOOKING OTHER
MEMBER.
IF I MY CAR FOR THE THE ISSUE --
IT'S THE NOTION THAT -- LET'S
SAY -- ONE LARGER COUNTIES
SERVICES GO LESS ANGELES THAT
PARTY HAS A SALES TAX BUT THEY
HAVE A DEVELOPER FEES WELL THE
WAY THE LANGUAGE I BELIEVE IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN IS THAT THEY'D
STILL BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR THIS
QUOTE SMALL COUNTIES COMPETITIVE
POT.
THAT'S THAT'S THE ISSUE IT AT
HAND AS FAR AS I SEE IT I DON'T
KNOW THAT THAT WAS.
INTENDED OR NOT IT'S JUST THE
WAY THAT.
HAVE BEEN WRITTEN SO THAT THAT'S
THE ONLY ISSUE THERE WOULD STILL
BE ABLE TO USE THAT MONEY DOES
THAT MATCH. FOR THEIR THEIR
FORMULA FUNDS -- TAKE THE SMALL
COUNTY PART CAN BE USED BY LOS
ANGELES IT'S A IT'S GOT TOO MANY
PEOPLE.
THAT WAY SO I I THINK I THINK WE
DIVIDE WEEKLY THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL.
PUTS A SUB ACCOUNT. FOR SMALL
[inaudible]
COUNTIES.
SO IT'S A SEGREGATED SUB ACCOUNT.
IT IS.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
OFFICE.
OF THE COMMITTEE.
SING NONE US UNDER THE LIKE.
TO CLOSE -- JUST THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION ON THIS ISSUE IS
SO.
LOT OF OUR WORK WITH A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND THANK YOU EVERYBODY
FOR WORKING HARD ON THIS URGE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS.
THANK SENATOR -- ALL I CAN SAY I
I WANT TO START OFF BY SAYING
THANK GOD FOR SELF HELP COUNTIES.
WITH OVER FOUR BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR GOING INTO THE SYSTEM.
THIS IS A THE THE LOCALITIES.
TAXING THEMSELVES SO THEY CAN BE
PART OF THE SUCCESS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORKS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEY ARE SHOULD
BE TREATED AS A PARTNER.
NOT AN ADVERSARY.
NOT ENOUGH ZERO POSITION BUT
ALSO JUST AS HEY HOW ABOUT A
THANK YOU -- ONE OF THINGS I
THINK ONE OF THE CONCERNS OF THE
CTC WAS BASICALLY THAT MONEY
WOULD BE STAGNATED.
WELL SENATOR BILL AND I SAID ON
THE C. T. SEEM WE WILL BE SURE
HER THAN WE WANT THAT MONEY
UTILIZED AS FAST AS POSSIBLE AND
NOBODY WILL BE SITTING ON MONIES
THAT ARE ALLOCATED OUT OF THIS
IT'S GOT TO BE SHOVEL READY
READY TO GO -- BUT I'M PROUD TO
WORK WITH YOU GET ON THIS -- AND
ANYTHING THAT CONNECTED WITH SB
ONE CENTER WE DID.
TOGETHER AND I APPRECIATE THAT --
YOU KNOW THE L. P. P. PROGRAM
WAS ALWAYS INTENDED TO WORK LIKE.
THIS IS WHAT YOU AND I HAD
DETERMINE IN OUR BILL.
JUST LIKE PROP ONE BE.
AND THIS IS A I WOULD SAY
PROBABLY THE CLOSEST THING THAT
WE K<c.cyan> TO I'M GLAD THAT THE</c>
CELL COALITION WAS ABLE TO COME.
TO A SOLUTION AFTER TWO YEARS --
AND A MAJORITY VOTE TO SUPPORT
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN AS AMENDED.
AND SO WITH THAT I'LL BE --
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL CENTER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL WE
HAVE A YEAR CURRY IS -- MOTION --
AND GET SAYS A SECOND.
PLEASE CALL.
FRAZIER THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
I BERMAN.
BIGELOW YOU WANT TO THE SHARE
OUR SURE I CAN ENHANCE
[inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP [inaudible]
I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HI GIPSON I AGREE SENATE
[inaudible]
MEDINA.
TINA I IN THIS AREA [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THERE IS SEVEN WORLD WE'VE ROLE
PLAN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU SENATOR. TO REMOVE ON TO
CENTER WIENER.
BECAUSE OF THE WHAT BILL WELL I
REMEMBER -- OKAY WHILE YOU'RE
GETTING READY CENTER WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND AND BACKTRACKING.
AND MAKE THE CALL ON YEAH.
SB TWO ELEVEN ON MOVE APPROVAL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG HI AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I TI<c.cyan>.</c>
SURE I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY OUR DAILY
AIDID [inaudible]
I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON R. GIPSON I'D GRAYSON.
MEDINA.
MEDINA I IN THIS AREA.
O'DONNELL.
THAT HAS TO LEAVE THE ROLL OVER
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
CENTER WHERE.
AS THREE TO SEVEN DOLLARS WILL
GOT ONE TWENTY SEVEN THE BILL.
OKAY WELL.
DO YOU EVEN WANT TO TESTIFY HA
HA HA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I KNOW
YOU WOULD.
WILL BE IT WILL BE BRIEF MESSAGE.
BONTA FIRST VISIT YOUR COMMITTEE
DON'T HAVE A TO BE HERE --
MISTER THANK YOU -- FOR HEARING
THIS TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFS WORK --
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL --
WE DID CROSS AMENDMENTS A WEEK
AGO IN A TIME TO TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED BY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON BY CALTRANS
AND SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US -- SB ONE TWENTY
SEVEN COLLEAGUES WILL ENSURE
THAT CALTRANS CONSIDERS SAFE
INTERSECTIONS SICK CROSSWALKS --
AND BIKE SAFETY ON PARTS OF THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM THAT -- ARE
USED AS LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT WHAT WE WOULD CONSIDER TO
BE A CLASSIC FREEWARE HIGHWAY.
THIS IS ABOUT -- ROAD SEGMENTS
THAT ARE TECHNICALLY STATE
HIGHWAYS BUT RUN THROUGH THE
MIDDLE OF CITIES AND TOWNS IN
THAT OPERATE A CITIES SURFACE
STREETS AND YOU WOULD NEVER KNOW.
WHERE STATE HIGHWAY IF YOU WERE
TO LOOK AT PLACES LIKE SANTA
MONICA BOULEVARD IN LA OR SAN
PABLO AVENUE AND YOU STAY OR
PORTIONS OF HIGHWAY ONE OR
NINETEEN AVENUE WERE BANNED US
IN SAN FRANCISCO?
I INTENTIONALLY IN MANY RURAL
COMMUNITIES -- STATE HIGHWAY
WILL OFTEN BE THE MAIN ROAD --
IN THAT STREET AND THAT IS THE
COMMUNITIES MAIN.
STREET -- THESE -- SEGMENTS CITY
STREETS -- HAVE MANY PEDESTRIANS
PEOPLE BIKING PEOPLE WAITING FOR
THE BUS -- AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE SAFE -- FOR
EVERYONE -- UNFORTUNATELY --
ALTHOUGH CALTRANS -- HAS.
ISSUED VARIOUS POLICIES
INDICATING THAT IT ONCE A TO
MAKE THE STREETS SAFER SO CALLED
COMPLETE STREETS -- WE HAVE NOT
SEEN IT NEARLY ENOUGH PROGRESS
AND SB ONE TWO SEVEN WILL ENSURE
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY SO THAT
CALTRANS BEGINS TO MAKE THAT
PROGRESS.
ARE THE BILL DOES A FEW THINGS
THAT ESTABLISHES AN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION ASSET BRANCH I
CALTRANS TO MEANINGFULLY TRACK
THE DEPARTMENT'S PROGRESS.
TOWARDS HIS BIKE AND PEDESTRIAN
GOALS IN TERMS INCLUDING INTERIM
GOALS OBJECTIVES AND ACTIONS --
THE BILL REQUIRES THAT THE ASSET
MANAGEMENT PLAN PRESCRIBER
PROCESS FOR COMMUNITY INPUT.
AND COMPLETE STREETS
IMPLEMENTATION.
PLAN WILL REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
TO INCLUDE SAFETY AND
ACCESSIBILITY FEATURES FOR
PEDESTRIANS TRANSIT USERS AND
CYCLE US A SUPPLEMENTARY ASSET
CLASSES -- IT WILL REQUIRE THE
CITY SEEING CALTRANS TO DEVELOP
A PLAIN LANGUAGE PERFORMANCE
REPORT. TO INCLUDE A DESCRIPTION
OF THE TYPE ACOSTA PEDESTRIAN
BIKE FACILITIES INCLUDING EACH
PROJECT.
AND FINALLY IT WILL REQUIRE THAT
WHEN THE STATE HIGHWAY AXES A
LOCAL ROAD THE PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT TEAM INCLUDE INPUT
FROM THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE I SPEAKING WITH --
WITH YOU TODAY OR THREE
WITNESSES -- FIRST AND FOREMOST --%
MOSES TRUJILLO WHO IS A FIFTH
GRADER AT MALCOLM X. ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN BERKELEY -- AND YOUR
AUNTS WE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION ONE
OF OUR SPONSORS -- AND THEN THE
COMMISSION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BY COALITION ALSO SPONSOR THANK
YOU.
WHICH IS GREAT.
YEAH THREE FOUR REAL.
HELLOMY NAME IS MOSES JAIL.
NICE TOWARD THE PULLOVER CLUB
THAT MALCOLM EXCELL ENTRY SCHOOL
IN BERKELEY.
IT ALL STARTED WHEN MY MOM SHARE
WITH ME AN ARTICLE SHE READ
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE WE SAID.
THAT IF WE DON'T MAKE DRASTIC
CHANGES IN OUR BEHAVIOR TOWARDS
THE PLANET IN ABOUT TWENTY YEARS
OUR WORLD COULD BASICALLY AND
FOR THIS REASON AND ONLY HALF OF
THE FULL OF OUR CLUB.
AND ALL CHILDREN AS FOR SB ONE
TWENTY SEVEN COMPLETE STREETS.
SO I JUST REGISTERED TO PULL
OVER CLUB AT SCHOOL FOR KIDS
WANTING TO HELP STOP CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AT THE FIRST MEETING AGAIN
EXPECTED TO THE CROWD.
BUT THIRTY SIX KIDS ATTENDED
WHICH WOULD MEAN THAT WE ALL
CARE ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
WANT TO THE ACTIVE IN MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
THE ORGANIZE MANY ACTIVITIES TO
TRY.
TO HELP STOP CLIMATE CHANGE OUR
BIGGEST WAS A MARCH FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE TO SUPPORT THE GLOBAL
EFFORT OF CHILDREN AROUND THE
WORLD.
THE MARCH TOOK PLACE ON ASHLEY
AVENUE WHICH IS HIGHWAY THIRTEEN
AND RUNS RIGHT IN FRONT OF OUR
SCHOOL.
THE MACHINE BY AND SUPPORTED BY
MANY OF THE DRIVERS SPEEDING
DOWN THE STREET.
NOW I LIVE JUST ONE LOCAL A FROM
OPEN NEXT.
I'M HOME AND I WALKED TO SCHOOL
TOGETHER EVERY DAY.
ALRIGHT.
CROSS WITH WHEN WE'RE AT THE
CROSSWALK MY MOM TELLS ME THAT
STREET IS REALLY BUSY AND
THERE'S A CHANCE OF HAVING AN
ACCIDENT THERE.
SO TO BE EXTRA CAREFUL.
SHE WON'T LET ME WALK ALONE EVEN
THOUGH I'M GOING TO BE IN FIFTH
GRADE AND I SCHOOLS ONE LOCALLY.
BECAUSE OF THE BUSY STREET IT
DOES NOT FEEL SAFE.
WE SEE A LOT OF CYCLISTS ANOTHER
WALKERS ON THE WAY AND I WANT
THEM TO FEEL SAFER.
TO THIS STREET BETWEEN MY HOUSE
AND MY SCHOOL IS BASICALLY A
FOUR LANE HIGHWAY. TWO LANES
FREE OF TRAFFIC GOING IN EACH
STRUCTURE WITH ONE CROSSING
GUARD AT THE LIGHT.
OFTEN CARS ARE SPEEDING DOING
AND WEAVING BETWEEN LANDS PAYING
MORE ATTENTION TO GETTING TO
WORK ON TIME AND TO THE CHILDREN
CROSSING THE STREETS.
I REMEMBER ONCE WELL I WAS
TRYING TO MAKE THE BULLET OF
CARMEL SWERVED INTO MEAN MY MOM.
MANY OF OUR FRIENDS IN BERKELEY
ENJOY WALKING OR CYCLING INSTEAD
OF USING CARS WE KNOW THAT THE
MAIN ISSUE OF CLIMATE CHANGE ARE
BECAUSE OF COURSE AND PEOPLE
USING TOO MUCH CASH.
WHICH CREATES EMISSIONS ARE BAD.
FOR THE EARTH THERE'S A THERE'S
A SOLUTION.
WE NEED TO TRY TO STOP USING
VEHICLES AND NOT BURN FOSSIL
FUELS.
I DIDN'T SAVE CROSSWALKS AND
BICYCLE FAST WILL HELP
TREMENDOUSLY.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE OR
REALIZE THAT WE'RE IN A CRISIS
AND THAT WE NEED TO ACT BEFORE
IT'S TOO LATE.
SEEN THAT OUR CITY OF BERKELEY
IS TAKING ACTIONS TO ADD THESE
OPTIONS TO OUR ROADS WILL
ENCOURAGE OTHERS TO MAKE BETTER
CHOICES IN TRANSPORTATION.
WHICH WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
OUR FUTURE AS A KID.
I CAN DO THINGS LIKE START THE
FULLER CLUB USE COSTS GROCERY
THAT ENCOURAGE MY FRIENDS HAVE
ZERO IS LUNCH.
WILL YOU DEPEND ON THE DAHLE
TURNED OUT THERE WERE PROBLEMS
LIKE REDUCING CAR EMISSIONS AND
PROVIDING SAFE WAYS FOR US TO
WALK AND RIDE BIKES TO SCHOOL.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON SB ONE TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
SO I DON'T THINK IT WOULD ASSIST
NEED TO SAY ANYTHING MORE.
HE'S COVERED IT ALL.
THEN I APPRECIATE YOU FOR DOING
THAT.
BASE WITH THE SPACE STATION AND
WE REPRESENT PLACE.
SHARE MEMBERS ANSWERING AND WE
WISH ALL YOUR AUNT'S WE ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT
THE BILL FOR THE REASONS STATED
BY.
THE AUTHOR AND OUR STAR WITNESS.
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE A SIX WITH
THIS.
WHEN THE COMMISSION WITH A
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION
ALSO ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WEEK
THAT APPRECIATED EVERYONE'S
LEADERSHIP HERE AND?
COMING TO A GOOD PLACE TO WITH
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
SO NO GO TO PUBLIC -- TEST ME
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TWENTY
HUNTER AND WE HAVE TO CITY IN
SACRAMENTO AND TRANSPORT THANK
YOU.
READING ARE SEE WHAT CAL STARTED
SUPPORT.
JONATHAN PLANNED OF THE CITY IN
SENATORS AND SUPPORT.
I WAS IN THAT THEIR DAVIS IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND FOR
PHILOSOPHY CALIFORNIA -- YOU
HUNKER DENNIS ON THE HEALTH OF
THE LATINO COALITION FOR HELL TO
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
MAY COLLINS ON BEHALF OF CALPERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CATHERINE GARCIA BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
ALICIA BROWN ON BEHALF OF WALK
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT --
STEVE ALL COMING UP THE AISLE
MADE CALTRAIN STATION COMMISSION
SUPPORT.
JEAN SEVEN HOUSE ON BEHALF OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTIONS
STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO --
ADDITIONALLY SPEAKING AS THE
MARIN MEMBER AT LARGE TO THE
CALTRANS DISTRICT FOR BICYCLE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR THE PAST
FIVE YEARS -- THERE'S NO DOUBT
IN MY MIND THE CALTRANS HEART IS
IN THE RIGHT PLACE BUT WE REALLY
NEED TO GIVE THEM MORE SO
STRUCTURE SO I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA ASKS
ME TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DAN PORTER ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
HELLO JONATHAN MATCHING THE SAFE
ARTS PARTNERSHIP WERE PROUD TO
BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
MOSES AND CAPTURED -- BETTER
THAN I EVER COULD AT THE THE
MISSION AND IN NEED OF OUR
ORGANIZATION AND THERE ARE
HUNDREDS MORE SCHOOLS.
JUST LIKE MALCOLMX -- ACROSS THE
STATE LOCATED DANGEROUSLY CLOSE --
TO TO STATE HIGHWAYS -- SO THIS
IS AN URGENT PROBLEM GETTING
AFFECTION WE WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
I ALSO WANTED TO ADD AND ME TO
FOR A WALK BY QUICKLY.
HI ESTHER VERA WITH CALIFORNIA
WALKS IN STRONG SUPPORT WE KNOW
THIS IS NEEDED AND MANY OF YOU
I'M ALSO RECEIVE VISUAL
FACTSHEETS SHOWING HOW THIS
IMPACTS YOUR DISTRICT SO
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU.
BILL MURPHY ON BEHALF OF ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTION NOR CAL AS WELL
AS THREE FIFTY ORG SILICON
VALLEY WITH STRONG SUPPORT.
MARION FURTHER IN ON BEHALF OF
THE BERKELEY CLIMATE HUB.
ON STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL PIMENTEL HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA TO
POOR ESCRIBIR.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
STILL LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE NO MOVE ONTO OP OF
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WHO LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR SHARE.
CONCERNS OF THE AUTHORS BILL
PLEASE STEP UP TO THE MIKE.
SO THIS IS A TWEENER IT'S GOOD
NEWS SO I GUESS COR BEHALF TO
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY OF
MONTEREY COUNTY -- WITH THE LACE
MEMBERS TO THE BILL WORKPLACE
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SO THANK YOU SEND OF TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS.
BIG SPEAKER [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WILL MOVE BACK O THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER GIBSON THE MISTER DALY
WAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST WANT
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR OF ONE
BRING IN THIS -- GOOD SENSE WILL
MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY THIS ONE
AYE AYES WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORT
BUT ALSO TO THE STAR WITNESS.
FOR DOING A YEOMAN'S JOB I TELL
YOU I'VE SEEN ADULTS GET UP HERE
AND YOU DID BETTER THAN THEY'VE
DONE SO I WANT TO COMMEND YOU ON
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
AND CERTAINLY WE'RE ALL EARS AND
YOU HAVE MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- MY
QUESTION IS SO I GUESS THE
BIGGER PICTURE OF FUNDING THE
SHOP PROGRAM -- AND OR SP.
ONE FUNDS WHICH FLOW NOW.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THAT MONEY
MAY END UP?
BEING SPENT.
IN SOME NEW WAYS -- TO THE TO DO
COMPLETE STREETS.
SURE AND JUST TO BE CLEAR
FUNDED BY THE SHOP -- ONE
CALTRANS IS GOING OUT TO A ROAD
RESURFACING OR WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE.
THAT MONEY ALREADY CAN GO TO THE
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE PROJECT
WHETHER IT'S ON HAVING A A
BRIGHTER CROSS WALKER BIKE LANES
ARE.
BETTER TRANSIT STOP THAT SAFER --
SO ALREADY.
CALTRANS FOR YOU OR CAN USE AND
DOES USE -- MONEY FOR THOSE
ASPECTS OF A OF A ROAD
RESURFACING PROJECT AND IN FACT
IT'S MORE EFFICIENT. TO DO THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA DO THAT WORK
WITH MUCH CHEAPER TO DO WHILE
YOU'RE ALREADY DOING A PROJECT --
AND THE AND CALTRANS OWN
POLICIES ALLOWS IT TO DO THAT
AND SAYS THE COMPLETE STREETS
ARE GOING TO HAPPEN -- THIS BILL
SIMPLY PUT BETTER STRUCTURE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY -- AROUND THAT SO
I CAN'T GIVE YOU AN EXACT
PERCENTAGE I THINK IT'LL BE A
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE IN THE BIG
SCHEME.
OF THINGS -- BUT I YOU KNOW THIS
IS ABOUT ENSURING THAT THESE
PROJECTS ACTUALLY HAPPEN -- AND
THAT WE HAVE SAFER STREETS FOR
EVERYONE.
SO MR DAILY WE DO HAVE A
REPRESENTED FROM CALTRANS HERE
THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO AS I
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
IF OF THE AGENCY WOULD COME UP
AND BE ABLE -- TO CLARIFY MISTER
DALY'S QUESTION WE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M DAN HERE'S THE
SYSTEM DIRECTOR FOR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS A CALTRANS.
AND I HAVE WITH ME JANET SPEND.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNA
SPENT NINE THE VISION SHE FOR A
QUARTERS DIVISION OF DESIGN IT
CALTRANS AND JUST TO CLARIFY WE
DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL AT THIS TIME WE'RE HERE TO
ANSWER THE TECHNICAL QUESTION.
BEFORE US TODAY.
SO SO WITH.
SO AT THIS TIME WE DON'T KNOW
THE ESTIMATE OF THE BILL ON THIS
WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING ON AN
INVENTORY OF BY COMPETITOR
SONY'S INTO THOSE -- THAT
REPRESENT THIS ON FACILITY TYPE.
THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PLACE
TYPES AND SO WE DON'T HAVE AN
ESTIMATE OF COST ON AT THIS TIME.
AND IT WILL REALLY VERY PROJECT
BY PROJECT -- AND SO THOSE
DETERMINATIONS ARE MADE -- YOU
KNOW OVER TIME AS EACH PROJECT.
IS DESIGNED SO IF IT WERE MISTER
DALY IS TRYING TO TO ASK IS.
INTENDED PURPOSE WAS.
AND AND WINDS OF UP HELD BY THE
VOTERS IN PROPOSITION
[inaudible]
SIX HIS.
HOW MUCH WOULD BE WE HAD AN
EXPECTATION HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AT THAT POINT IN
TIME?
THAT'S THE ONE WITH THE FIFTY
NINE BILLION DOLLARS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND CALIFORNIA.
THAT THE SHOP WOULD BE UTILIZED
FOR MAINTENANCE OF THE OF THE OF
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
SO WHAT HE'S SAYING IS HOW MUCH
ADDITIONAL MONEY WOULD BE.
A UTILIZED.
IN THIS ROUND NOW WE KNOW THAT
YOU DO IT.
TO SOME EXTENT.
BUT WAS SB ONE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT MISTER DAVIS ASKING.
WE NEED TO KNOW AND PLEASE IF
YOU CAN GIVE US SOME KIND OF
SOFT NUMBER.
AT SOME POINT IN TIME.
WHAT THIS WOULD TAKE AWAY FROM
THE MAINTENANCE?
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE HIGHWAYS
TO DO THIS BECAUSE WE ONLY HAVE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
EIGHTY P..
SO ARE WE AUGMENTING A. T. P.
WITH THE SHOP AS WELL AS THE
QUESTION.
OKAY SO UNDERSTANDING.
THAT'S THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT I
WAS REALLY MIKE.
YES WHEN I APPRECIATE THAT I
MEAN IN IN IN IN OTHER WORDS IF
IF 2% OF OF OF SHOP FUNDS TODAY
ARE -- END UP BEING SPENT ON
COMPLETE STREETS.
A PEDESTRIAN PROVE MEN'S -- AND
SO FORTH WHICH I WANNA SAY
CLEARLY I AM STRONGLY IN FAVOR
OF THOSE TYPES OF IMPROVEMENTS.
ON THE OTHER HAND WE NEED TO
KNOW -- HOW THIS WILL AFFECT OUR
FUNDING PROGRAM?
IF IT'S 2% TODAY AND WITH THESE
NEW WITH OF FORMALIZING IT
ADVERTISING IT MORE CLEARLY.
BROADCASTING IT WILL IT GO MAYBE
23% OR 4%.
OF THE FLOW AND IT'S A LITTLE
CONCERNING OF CALTRANS DOESN'T.
KNOW THAT.
YET -- WE'RE NOTMEAN IT IS IT'S
HARD TO MAKE POLICY ON THAT
BASIS BUT IT.
AS AS THE CHAIR SAID AS OR EVEN
A SOFT NUMBER AVAILABLE TODAY
HOW HOW WILL HOW WILL HOW WILL
FUNDS FUNDS SPENT CHANGE UNDER
THIS BILL [inaudible]
STATE WHAT.
SO -- COMPLETE TO SALOMON'S ARE
INCLUDED IN THE PROJECTS IN THE
SHOP -- AND SO IT BECOMES VERY
DIFFICULT TO TRY TO PARSE OUT
HOW MUCH IS SPENT ON EACH
DIFFERENT PIECE OF THAT PROJECT
BECAUSE THERE'S VARIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL SUPPORT DESIGN
COSTS -- THAT SERVE MULTIPLE
PURPOSES OF THE PROJECTS BECOMES
VERY DIFFICULT TO TRY TO
QUANTIFY THE ACTUAL COST ELEMENT
OF ANY PIECE OF A PROJECT AS A
RESULT OF THAT.
ALSO AT THIS TIME -- YOU KNOW WE
COULD TRY TO SEE IF WE CAN GET
SOMETHING TO YOU LATER AT A
LATER DATE -- TO AT A COST
ESTIMATE BUT AT THIS POINT IT
BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT TO DO
THAT SUFFICE YESTERDAY IT WILL
LIKELY GO UP.
WHATEVER THE CURRENT STATE OF
AFFAIRS IS IT WILL LIKELY
INCREASE.
IF THIS BILL BECOMES LAW.
BECAUSE IT'LL BE FOUR IT'LL BE
FORMALIZED AND IT'LL BE
BROADCAST. TO IN AN AND I'M NOT
SAYING THAT'S A BAD THING IT'S
JUST WILL BE IT IT'S GOOD TO
KNOW THAT.
I I THINK -- AND I REALLY
RESPECT THE QUESTION I I AND I I
MEAN IT'S IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND.
THAT WE'RE NOT INTRODUCING A NEW
CONCEPT CURRENTLY SHOP PROGRAMS
FOR FOR MAINTENANCE -- DO
INCLUDE COMPLETE THREE ELEMENTS
AND CAL TRANS HAS POLICY CENTER
THIS SHOULD HAPPEN -- THE
CHALLENGES THAT IT'S NOT
STRUCTURE AND SO SOMETIMES IT
HAPPENS SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T --
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY YOU HAVE TO BRING A
LOCAL COMMUNITY AND TO CONSULT
AND THERE ARE THERE IS
FLEXIBILITY -- THAT'S BUILT AND
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO PUT A
STRAIGHT JACKET ON THE AGENCY%
BUT WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THESE POLICIES THAT HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE FOR A WHILE --
ACTUALLY MEANS SOMETHING AND
HAVING A STOCKS IN THE BOOKS --
WILL WILL DO THAT.
GOOD IS IT FAIR TO SAY I MEAN I
USE THE WORD -- YOUR FORMALIZING
IT.
YOUR STRUCTURING IT OR YOU'RE
SUGGESTING THAT IT BE STRUCTURED
AND BROADCAST YES MORE CLEARLY.
THANK YOU.
THIS FROM THE JOB YOUR MAYBE --
MAYBE CALTRANS CAN AS APSO HOUSE
SHOT FUNDS ALLOCATED NOW.
SO THE THE SHOP FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED BASED ON OUR ASSET
MANAGEMENT PLAN SO WE HAVE AN
INVENTORY OF ALL OUR ASSETS FOR
THE THE PRIMARY ASSETS.
AND WE ALLOCATE THE FUNDS BASED
ON THE THE NEED A CONDITION OF
THOSE ASSETS.
AND IS IS.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING AND MAYBE
THE OTHER CAN CORRECT THIS IS A
DOES DOES THIS BILL CHANGED THE
WAY -- SHOP PROJECTS ARE
PRIORITIZED ANYWAY. TWENTY EIGHT
IS IT DOES A PRIORITIZE --
BIKING -- WALKING PROJECTS OVER
SAY MY CONCERN IS THAT YOU KNOW
WE WHEN YOU SHOP FOR LET'S SAY --
EXPANDING -- CAPACITY ON HOW IN
ANY.
NINE A WITH THIS COMPETE WITH
THAT OR ARE THE SEPARATE
PROJECTS OR THESE ARE THE ODDS
ARE PART OF THE SERVICE THERE'S
A PRICE SO FOR EXAMPLE IF AND A
USES THEM BECAUSE THE CHAIR AND
I SPOKE ABOUT IT -- HIGHWAY ONE
BECAUSE YOU'RE HALF MOON BAY
NINE CEMETERY COUNTY IF IT IT'S
IF IF THAT ROVER BEING WORKED ON
THEY WOULD HAVE TO ALSO.
DO FRANKLY WITH OUR CURRENT
POLICY SAYS THEY SHOULD DO IS
EVALUATE -- AND DECIDE WHETHER --
TO IT MAKES SENSE TO PUT
COMPLETE ST ELEMENTS ARE THERE
AND ACTUALLY BALL THROUGH.
ON THAT SO IT'S NOT LIKE IT'S
TRIGGERING NECESSARILY NEW
PROJECTS THE PROJECTS THAT ARE
ALREADY HAPPENING IN MAKING SURE
WE'RE DOING IT -- IN A COMPLETE --
IN A COMPLETE WELL SO I DON'T DO
IT AS COMPETITION -- IT DOES --
PROVIDE THAT -- THESE --
FACILITIES BY CONTRAST RAN ARE
CONSIDERED SUPPLEMENTARY ASSETS
CALTRANS ALREADY HAS
CLASSIFICATIONS OF ITS ASSETS
AND SO THE FINAL SUPPLEMENTARY
AWESOME.
THANK YOU SO I UNDERSTAND THAT'S
THE SECOND PART OF THE THE BILL
THE THE I GUESS THE FOR THE
FIRST FOUR AND I GUESS MAYBE
THAT THE AUTHOR TOUCHES AGAINST
IT DOES THIS BILL CHANGE THE
ASSET.
MANAGEMENT PLAN AND HOW IT'S HOW
THE PRIOR.
TO SURE I CAN ADD TO THAT AND
HAVE YOU GUYS BECAUSE WELL AT
WHAT IT DOES IS IT IN ORDER TO
OPERATIONALIZE WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ACHIEVE HERE.
IT IS ADDING TO THE TRANSITION
ASSET MANAGEMENT PLAN COMPLETE
STREETS AS SUPPLEMENTARY ASSET
CLASSES WITH THAT WILL DO IS
ACTUALLY HELP WITH SETTING COST
PROJECTIONS AND ALSO PERFORMANCE
PROJECTIONS AND TARGETS.
SO THAT CAN GET TO AS TO YOU
KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING TO GO AND
THEN THERE'S GOING TO BE
REPORTING WHICH ALREADY HAPPENS
WITH THE THE ASSET MANAGEMENT
PLAN THAT THEN WE'LL BE ABLE TO
FOLLOW HOW THIS IS -- CHANGING
OVER TIME.
THE DISCUSSIONS AGREE WITH THAT
THAT IT DOES THEN IT DOES CHANGE
THE ASSET MANAGEMENT PLAN.
IT DOES IT DOES IT JUST THE ARE
SUBMITTED PLAN BECAUSE IT AS THE
BIKE IMPAIRED IN TRANSIT
FACILITIES OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR THIS BILL.
SENIOR CENTER FOR CLOSE.
HI THANK YOU VERY MUCH I YOU
KNOW I THINK WE CLEARLY LIVE AND
YOUR OF LIMITED RESOURCES MORE
OF THAT JUST LIKE WE ALL ARE AND
WE WANT.
TO MAKE SURE OF THAT OUR
HIGHWAYS AND ROADS ARE IN GOOD
CONDITION -- WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE -- THAT OUR STREETS
ARE SAFE NONE OF THIS IS
MUTUALLY -- INCONSISTENT -- THIS
IS ABOUT TRYING TO RISE
EVERYTHING UP UNDERSTANDING --
THAT WE NEED MORE RESOURCES --
FOR EVERYTHING -- AND SO I THINK
WE STRUCK A GOOD BALANCE IN THIS
BILL I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I THINK MOSES FOR TAKING SOME
HIS US SUMMER BREAK.
TO SPEND IT WITH US TODAY AND
ADVOCATE LEARNING DEMOCRACY
EARLY ON AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
YOU JOIN THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO FIGHT FOR THE
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR SP ONE AND
I THANK YOU FOR THAT -- WHEN WE
PASS SB WHEN THE STATE WAS
FACING A WHEN I SAID FIFTY NINE
BILLION I WAS WRONG SEVENTY NINE
BILLION DOLLAR BACKLOG OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ON THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM?
ONLY MISTER BY TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS.
UNFORTUNATELY SB ONE REVIEWS DID
NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW FIVE POINT.
TWO BILLION DOLLARS AND NOT ALL
OF THAT'S GOING TO SHOP -- TO
FIX THAT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OF
THAT MONEY.
IT I REALLY DO COUPLE MIKE WHO
IS YOU MENTIONED -- HAVE
HAPPENED A WE TALKED ABOUT IT
HILL AS I'VE BEEN UP THERE HAVE
BEEN AND HIKED ON I WILL.
AND SEE THE BENEFITS SIX THIS
GIGGLING.
YOU KNOW CALTRANS CONTINUES TO
BILL COMPLETE STREETS INTO HIS
PROGRAM AND WHEN AND WHERE
FEASIBLE.
AND YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT THE
PRACTICALITY OF THIS.
BEING IMPLEMENTED WHERE.
YOU KNOW IT WE HAVE SOME
PARAMETERS -- SO THAT SOME DATA
DRIVEN NECESSITY RATHER THAN.
GLOBALLY THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
IN RURAL COUNTIES WHERE IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO BE ABLE TO
DO THIS AND THAT'S WHAT I HAVE
TO SEE IN THIS BILL.
YOUR I'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT I
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT A MEMBER.
I HAVE NOT SEEN THAT AMENDMENT --
BUT I THINK THAT THERE IS A
PURPOSE AND A PLACE.
BUT ALL OF THIS COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED -- THAT WOULD BE.
I THINK FAVORABLE BECAUSE OF
WHAT IT ACCOMPLISHES.
IN PROTECTION OF LIFE.
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND ALSO WHAT
MOSES TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
HIMSELF.
AND SO -- I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
BILL TODAY.
I AM CONCERNED THAT THE BILL ON
MAY IMPACT THE STATE'S ASSET
MANAGEMENT -- APPROACH.
HEY COULD HAMPER CALTRANS
ABILITY TO MANAGE STATE ASSETS
BASED ON A CONDITIONS IN NEED
AND I THINK WE NEED TO REFINE.
AS YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT AND
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION.
I WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THIS -- YOU KNOW YOU'RE
ON THE RIGHT TRACK AND I KNOW
YOU'RE PASSIONATE AND YOU'RE
LIKE A DOG WITH A BONE WITH THIS.
AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT I
REALLY DO -- SO I THINK TO
PROTECT THE HEART GAINES OF SB
ONE AND TO MAKE THE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM SAY FOR ALL USERS WE NEED
TO BE ABLE.
TO JOIN AYE.
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN ABSOLUTELY -- WITH THAT.
I'LL BE SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY.
BUT I ASSURE YOU.
THAT IF WE CAN'T WORK TOGETHER
AND GET THE SS CITY OF THAT I'M
LOOKING.
FOR THAT I WILL SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TO IT BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AND WE WILL HAVE A DISCUSSION
AGAIN IN THESE CHAMBERS.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR DILIGENCE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL -- I HAVE A FIRST BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY IN
THE SECOND BY MISTER GIPSON.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
AND I BIGELOW [inaudible]
Q. I'VE.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ ARIAN O'DONNELL.
THE BILL HAS A WILL HAVE THEIR
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
CONGRADULATIONS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FAVORITE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE CENTER THANK.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ONTO CENTER
ARE STILL OUT OF THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE.
SB FOUR OH FIVE YOU IN PERSON
WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
TODAY I'M PRESENTING.
SENATE BILL FOUR OH FIVE WHICH
WILL AUTHORIZE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TO CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM
DEMONSTRATING THE VIABILITY.
OF USING RECYCLED BRADENTON ROAD
REPAIR AND MAINTENANCE.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
SB ONE AS YOU KNOW WHICH
ALLOCATED PROXY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS FOR REPORTING
REPAIRING CALIFORNIA STREETS AND
ROADS.
WITH SENATE BILL FOUR OH FIVE WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE CURRENT REPAVING PROCESS
WHICH LEAVES MILLIONS OF TONS OF
ASPHALT PAVEMENT STACKED PILED
STOCKPILED.
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING ELEVEN THE SENATE
DISTRICTS AND FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS.
THERE IS NO NEXT THERE IS NO
SECONDARY MARKET FOR THIS
MATERIAL.
CALTRANS CURRENTLY ALLOWS UP
240%.
OF THESE RECYCLED GRINDING TO BE
ADDED TO NEW ASPHALT IS ST
REHABILITATION PROJECTS.
HOWEVER THIS BILL INTENT TO SET
UP A PILOT PROJECT THAT WILL
DEMONSTRATE A NEW REPAVING
PROCESS TO REVIEW JUST 8521100%.
OF THESE GRAND EACH.
SIMILAR WORK IS CURRENTLY UNDER
WAY BY COMPANIES IN INDIANA AND
NEW YORK.
NOT ONLY WILL THIS BILL.
AND THE PROCESSING AND
ACKNOWLEDGING THIS BILL.
THIS NEW PROCESSING REAL WILL
REDUCE THE LOOMING ENVIRONMENTAL
PROBLEMS THAT COME FROM HAVING.
THESE HUGE ASPHALT PILES.
NEXT TO WORSE NEIGHBORHOODS OUR
SCHOOLS INCLUDING REPORTS OF
NOSE BLEEDS AND BREATHING
PROBLEMS FOR THOSE IN THE MEDIA
DARIUS.
BUT THERE IS ALSO ADDED BENEFIT
OF REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SINCE THERE WILL BE NO
NEED TO DIG UP IN MIND FOR
ADDITIONAL ASPHALT.
AND TRANSPORTED TO THROUGH THESE
WORK SITES WHICH ARE OFTEN MILES
AWAY FROM THE ORIGINAL MINING
SITES.
I HAVE CONTINUED TO WORK WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS SPECIFICALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASPHALT
PAVEMENT ASSOCIATION.
I HAVE AGREED TO TAKE ASSEMBLY
FOR I'M A FAN BEAT ASSEMBLY
FLOOR AMENDMENTS.
ADDRESSING THEIR CONCERNS
REGARDING WHO WILL BE PERFORMING
THE EVALUATION AND THE STUDY
CONTAINED IN THIS BILL.
SENATE BILL FOUR OH FIVE HAS NO
NO VOTES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND WITH ME I HAVE JOHN
CORCORAN -- IF YOU HAVE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF YOU NEED.
FIRST OF A SECOND TERM -- WHICH
LIKE TO TESTIFY TO ANY COMPONENT
OF YOUR THE AUTHORS BILLS OR IF
YOU NEED.
THE LARGER.
NUMBERS OF PUBLICLY LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL -- TEMPERAMENTS
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS AND FULL SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS
KATE ON HUGE AROUND WITH THE
STATE COUNCIL LABORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THEATER IN
OPPOSITION OF CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS BILL PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME IN THE
REPRESENTING.
YES JEFF SIEVERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ASPHALT PAVEMENT
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR TO STAFF AS WELL AS THE
SPONSORS THE BILL FOR ADDRESSING
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS AND WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE SENATOR
MENTIONED WE WILL BE REMOVING
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PERFECT.
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE CENTER WAS LIKE
CLOSE YES AND MISTER CHAIRED AND
AND MEMBERS PLEASE I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTERS A LOT OF I
THIS FOR US TO I CAN TELL.
THIS BILL ALLOWS LA COUNTY TO DO
SOMETHING ALREADY HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO DO.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT IF IT'S
IMPORTANT YOUR DISTRICT THEN I
AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOU IN THAT
THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND YOU WILL
TAKE HIM IN THIS AS YOU SAID AS
A PROMISED ON THE FLOOR.
AND THAT WILL TAKE IN THE PAVE
ASSOCIATIONS WITH OPPOSITION
AWAY WHICH IS GOOD BECAUSE I'M
GLAD YOU WERE ABLE TO COME TO A
COMPROMISE WITH THEM THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
THANK YOU ALL -- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS WERE
THE BILL.
WE HAD MEDINA.
AND DALY IS A SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS FRAZIER HI
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU
VERY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HI GIPSON I'D GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ ARIAN O'DONNELL.
THAT HAS NINE LEAD ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU ALL
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO SENATOR HILL.
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE CENTER WHEN
YOU HAVE A CHANCE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT
TO BEGIN BY.
COMMITTING TO ADDRESSING THE
COMMITTEE'S CONCERNS VERY VALID
CONCERNS HIGHLIGHTED ON PAGE
FIVE AND SIX OF THE ANALYSIS.
OVER THE SUMMER RECESS WILL WORK
ON THOSE I AM A LOOPHOLE IN
CURRENT LAW.
MAKES IT LEGAL FOR PASSENGERS TO
SMOKE CANNABIS IN A PARTY BUS
Là M<c.cyan> TAXI OR TNC.</c>
AS A RESULT SOME PARTY BUS IN
THE MALL OPERATORS ARE OFFERING
CANNABIS DISPENSARY TOWARDS
SIMILAR TO EXISTING TOWARDS FOR
WINERIES OR BROUGH REACH.
MODELED AFTER STATUTES FOR BEER
AND WINE BUSES IN LIMOS SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE WILL PROHIBIT
CANNABIS USE IN THESE VEHICLES
UNLESS THE SAFETY STANISLAVSKY
STANDARDS ARE FOLLOWED.
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE MAKES IT
ILLEGAL FOR A PASSENGER IN A
PARTY BUS OR Là M<c.cyan> TO SMOKE</c>
OR VAPOR CANNABIS UNLESS THE
DRIVER'S COMPARTMENT IS SEALED.
IT SEALED OFF IN SEPARATELY
VENTILATED.
THE BILL ALSO PROHIBITS ANYONE
UNDER TWENTY ONE FROM BEING ON
BOARD IF CANNABIS SMOKERS
PRESENT THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL
IS TO ENSURE THAT THE DRIVER IS
NOT IMPAIRED.
IF CANNABIS SPOKE IS CONSUMED IN
ONE OF THESE FOR HIGHER VEHICLES
I WANT TO REINFORCE THAT UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
CANNABIS USE IS ALLOWED IN BUSES
LIMOS AND TAXIS WITHOUT ANY
REGULATION OR CONSUMER
SAFEGUARDS.
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE AS NECESSARY
TO CLOSE THIS LOOPHOLE
INAPPROPRIATELY REGULATE THESE
BUSINESSES.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE OPPOSITION IN THE BILL
HAS BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED
TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS
SPECIFICALLY THE CURRENT VERSION
OF THE BILL.
IS LIMITED TO JUST BUSES IN
LIMOS REQUIRES THAT THESE
OPERATORS MEET ALL REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR CHARTER PARTY
CARRIERS INCLUDING PERMITTING BY
THE PC.
AND INSPECTIONS BY THE CHP
REQUIRES A THIRD PARTY LICENSED
ENGINEER TO VERIFY THAT THE
VEHICLES PARTITION EFFECTIVELY
LIMITS THE PASSAGE OF SMOKE TO
THE DRIVER.
ADDS ENFORCEMENT LANGUAGE WHICH
OBJECTS OPERATORS TO PENALTIES
AND PERMIT REVOCATION FOR
VIOLATING THE LAW.
AND AGAIN I WANT TO MENTION THAT
I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH THAT YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
AND STAKEHOLDERS ON ADDRESSING
ANY OUTSTANDING ISSUES AND
CONCERNS I FEEL.
SIX TWENTY FIVE STRIKES A
BALANCE THAT ALLOWS FOR CANNABIS
USE ON BUSES IN LIMOS WALL
PROTECTING THE DRIVER PASSENGERS
AND CONSUMERS.
I THINK THERE ARE WITNESSES HERE
TO SPEAK ON THE BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TEACHER NAME IN WHO
REPRESENTING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OUR ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS OVER SIX HUNDRED BRANDS
AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
WE ARE VERY PLEASED AT TO
SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY FIVE WHICH
PROHIBITS THE INGESTION OF
CANNABIS AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS
IN CHARTER BUSES IN LIMOUSINES
AND LESS THE DRIVER'S
COMPARTMENT IS PETITION DOES THE
AUTHOR STATED.
CANNABIS TOURISM IS ON THE RISE
AND REPRESENTS A KEY OPPORTUNITY
FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND COLORADO CANNABIS TOURISM
HAS GROWN 51% SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
TOURISTS LOGGED IN NEARLY
EIGHTEEN MILLION CANNABIS YOU
STAYS IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ALONE.
CALIFORNIA IS FOLLOWING CLOSE
BEHIND WITH CANNABIS TOURISTS
POPPING UP THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN OTHER STATES -- THE THE
ISSUES OR THE PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL ARE SIMPLY BEST PRACTICES
WITH THIS AUTHOR IS LOOKING TO
DO IS CODIFY THESE BEST
PRACTICES INTO LAW AND MAKE
THESE REQUIREMENTS.
SIMPLY PUT SB SIX TWENTY FIVE IS
A STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL THAT
ESTABLISHES APPROPRIATE INDUSTRY
STANDARDS FOR CANNABIS TOURISM
WHILE IMPROVING THE SAFETY OF
BOTH PASSENGERS AND DRIVERS FOR
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL AND REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH POND
AND WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA BUSES
CESSATION WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND WE'RE JUST HOPING
THAT AT SOME POINT.
THEY'LL BE A PROVISION TO
PENALIZE -- THE ACTUAL PERSON
WHO WANTS TO SMOKE IN VIOLATION
BECAUSE THERE'S NO VIOLATION
TIMELY AND IT NOW.
SO I THINK WITH THE AUTHOR WE'D
BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT PIECE THAT IF SOMEONE.
IS VIOLATING THE LAW -- THEN
THERE'S A PENALTY ON THAT PERSON
NO DIFFERENT THAN FOR ALCOHOL
NOW I IT WOULD BE ON THAT
PERSON'S SO WHERE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THAT
PIECE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION -- FIRST OF ALL
CLARIFICATION THE ANALYSIS LISTS
US AS BEING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
WE ARE NOT WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL SUPPORT POSITION WE WERE
OPPOSED TO THE ORIGINAL VERSION
OF THE BILL.
WE WORKED WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND WITHDREW OUR
OPPOSITION.
THAT SAID WE EMBRACE THE
COMMITTEE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT
WILL MAKE FOR THE BILL EVEN
BETTER -- IN A SURE THAT WE
WON'T HAVE PROBLEMS WITH.
SECONDHAND SMOKE WITH MARIJUANA
IMPAIRING A IN IN IMPAIRING THE
DRIVER -- AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THE COMMITTEE
ONE FINAL THING I'D BE REMISS.
IF I DIDN'T COMMENT ON JUST THE
FOR PROFESSIONALISM OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THIS IS WHAT.
JESSA UNRUH HAD IN MIND WHEN HE
TALKED ABOUT THE INCREASED
PROFESSIONALISM OF A FULL TIME
LEGISLATURE'S USED.
EXCELLENT PIECE OF WORK.
WE CAN JUST DROP THE MIKE ON
THAT.
ONE YEAH SO ANYWAY ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF THE OTHERS BILL.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FEEL
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NINE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
OF THE AUTHOR.
WHO IS AGUIAR-CURRY?
SO -- FOR DINNER WITH THE MULLIN
DEALS AND MY NIECE AND NEPHEW WE
HAVE DISCUSSED ABOUT THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE TRY TO BRING
SOMETHING TO THE TABLE PERIODIC
THEY TALK ABOUT BILLS IN THE
PROCESS.
AND SO I'M GOING TO SHARE A
COUPLE OF THEIR CONCERNS -- AND
GRANTED THEY HAVE READ THE BILL
BUT I'M GONNA TELL YOU THE ONES
THAT.
THE CONCERNED ABOUT.
SECONDHAND SMOKE.
IN A CONFINED AREA -- INDIVIDUAL
CONTROL OF CONSUMPTION.
THAT HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE THAT
IF IF YOU'VE HAD TOO MUCH SMOKE
IN A THE CAR OR WHATEVER.
OTHER INDIVIDUALS MAY NOT
APPRECIATE THAT SMOKE.
FOR GETTING INTO A BAR I MEANT
RENTING ONE OF THESE -- VEHICLES
AND THE RESIDUAL SMOKE IS STILL
IN IT AS WE KNOWS AND THERE'S NO
SMOKING ROOMS BUT YOU STILL KNOW
IT'S BEEN SMOKED IN RIGHT.
SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
QUESTIONS THEY COME UP WITH JUST
IF YOU.
DON'T THINK YOU -- AND THE ISSUE.
RELATED TO THIS BILL IS.
YOU WOULDN'T BE ON THIS BUS
UNLESS YOU WERE INTENDING TO
PARTAKE OF OF CANNABIS OR GOING
TO ARE GOING TO A CANNABIS
FACILITY WHERE YOU WOULD PARTAKE
THERE THEN GET ON THE BUS.
THE IDEA IS THAT -- THIS IS LIKE
A UP OF A LIQUOR TOUR WINE TOUR
APPEAR TO OR WHERE THEY WOULD BE
DOING THAT THE CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE IS TO IN THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT NO ONE
ELSE.
IS AFFECTED BY THAT THROUGH
EXTERIOR GOING OUT A WINDOW THAT
THE SMOKING AFFECTION ONE
OUTSIDE OR GET INTO THAT THE
DRIVER OF THE VEHICLE SO THE THE
IDEA IS THAT THOSE THAT ARE
SMOKING AND PARTICIPATING IN
THIS AND PARTAKING OF THAT.
THE EXPECTATION IS THAT THEY
WOULD FEEL THE EFFECTS OF THAT
THE GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE PROTECTED -- WHEN THEY
GET OUT OF THERE IN SOME WAY
THAT THEY'RE NOT GETTING INTO A
VEHICLE SOMEHOW WE'RE GOING TO
TRY?
TO LOOK AT THAT SOMEHOW TO BUT
THE PARTY BUS BUS BILLS THAT
I'VE HAD PREVIOUSLY TO THIS HAVE
LOOKED AT MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT GETTING ONTO A
VEHICLE BUT THIS IS.
MAINLY FOR THOSE WHO ARE --
DESIGNATED.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT BEHAVIOR
AND ACTIVITY -- IN THE ANOTHER
ONE WAS -- THE WINDOWS ROLLED UP.
AND GET TAUGHT ME ROLL DOWN THE
WINDOWS AND THE SMOKE'S COMING
OUT OF IT IS IF THAT'S NOT
ALLOWED IN THIS BILL THEY
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED THROUGH THAT
SMOKE TO LEAVE THAT VEHICLE
THAT'S WHY IN THE DRIVER'S AREA.
THE SMALL CAN'T.
IN FUEL IMPACT THE DRIVER THE
DRIVER IS AT ALL.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE AN ENGINEER
GOING INTO DESIGN MAKING SURE
THAT THAT IS CLOSED IN AIR TIGHT
TO THAT THERE'S NOT -- THE SEAL
CAN'T BE BROKEN AND THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO HAVE SMOKE.
EXITING THE THE VEHICLE AS WELL
COULD THAT BE A SAFETY ISSUE.
WITH THE WINDOWS ARE CAN BE
ROLLED DOWN.
BUT THERE'S ALWAYS A LOT ANY
BASIS FOR THAT THERE ARE WAYS TO
BREAK THE WINDOW YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S ALSO PART OF PARTY BUSES
AND LIMO ZINES NOW THE VENT
WINDOWS DON'T GO UP AND DOWN.
THERE HAS TO BE A AN ABILITY TO
TO BREAK THAT WINDOW IN ORDER TO
ACCESS IT THE TICKET.
EXIT THE VEHICLE SO I'M GETTING
WITH THIS IS THAT -- I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT
THERE'S A QUESTIONS OF PEOPLE
ASK.
ME GENERAL QUESTIONS EITHER
ASKING -- IT'S ONE THING TO
MAYBE TAKE A CANNABIS BROUGH --
MY AN EDIBLE AND YOU GET THAT
CHOICE.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE IN A BUS NOT
EVERYBODY HAS THE CHOICE.
AND IF I MAY MISTER MYSTERY HOW
IS THIS IS MY CLOTHES THE THE
CURRENT LAW TODAY ALLOW SOMEONE
TO DO THAT IN A VEHICLE --
WITHOUT ANY.
RESTRICTIONS RESERVATIONS OR
ACCESS ISSUES TO THE DRIVER OR
ANYTHING ELSE THAT'S CURRENT LAW
WE'RE TRYING TO TIGHTEN THAT'D
MAKE IT BETTER.
THANK YOU DR OF NUMBERS THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO HAVE QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHOR.
SO I WILL TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES THANK YOU SO MUCH I DO
HAVE A FIRST PLACE A MEMBER
GIPSON SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN -- THANK YOU SENATOR HELP
THANK YOU MISTER KING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS -- OBVIOUS FOR
YOUR BILL TODAY WITH YOUR
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
MYSELF ON THE AMOUNT IS SO WITH
THAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THERE IS NO
ROOM FOR DOUBT THAT THE DRIVERS
IT IS SEALED OFF.
A FROM THE PASSAGE PRICE JUST
FEEL IT'S IRONIC THAT WE
CONTINUE TO PUSH THIS.
SOCIETAL ISSUE AND WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE ANY KIND OF LAW FIRM
PAYMENT.
WHILE DRIVING.
HELLO STILL CLASS CLASS WONDER
OF FIVE FAT.
SO I MEAN WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
THIS BUT I THINK ONE OF THE
URGENCY IS OUR IMPAIRMENT AND I
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
KIND OF TECHNOLOGICAL.
ADVANCEMENTS SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY PROTECT PEOPLE FROM
THIS.
HORRIFIC OPPORTUNITY TO KILL
SOMEBODY -- AND I AGREE BUT I
ALSO BELIEVE WE SHOULD HOLD
CHARTER PARTY CARRIERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ALLOWING MINORS.
TO CONSUME CANNABIS JUST AS WE
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ALLOWING THEM TO DRINK.
I ALSO BELIEVE THE STATE SHOULD
NOT MANDATE THAT EMPLOYEE SHOULD
BE PRESENT THE BACK OF THE
VEHICLE WHERE THERE'S PEOPLE
GETTING STONED.
OR THEY CAN GET STONE FROM
SECONDHAND SMOKE.
SO WITH THAT YOU KNOW YOU SAY
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
I THINK THAT YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK I KNOW THAT YOU'RE IN A
PROTECTION MODE. FOR THOSE FOR
THE PUBLIC.
HAVE BUT I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
SEE THE HIGHWAY PATROL COME
THROUGH THAT STUDY MONEY. FOR
THE DRIVING IMPAIRED GOING
FORWARD WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHIU.
I THANK YOU CAN CHIU AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO DAILY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP NO FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON R. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
[inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA I IN THIS AREA IN
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL AYE.
GIVE -- EIGHT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE CONTRAST SO MEMBERS CAN
LOOK FOR WORKERS OR THANK YOU
COLLEGE LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
SO LOOKS LIKE THIS SENATE IS IN
SESSION -- FROM THREE O'CLOCK SO
WE'RE WAITING FOR A COUPLE
MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO TRAVEL
TRANSVERSAL HERE.
SO -- HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE --
TO HAVE A SENATOR TO BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY SOON.
LET'S GO AHEAD LIFT THE CALL ON
SOME OF THE BILLS THAT WE'VE
ALREADY HERS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
JUST SHALL NOT JUST ONE OF THE
HAVE SHOWN UP -- TO VOTE ON THAT.
IT.
WAS GOOD STROKE CONSENT COLOR
PLEASE I WILL MOVE THROUGH IT.
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR BERMAN.
BERMAN I Q..
CHIU I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
MEDINA.
AND I NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ONE
TWENTY SEVEN BIGELOW
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I DEEP [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
ENGINE FIVE OUT OF FIVE FILE
ITEM TO CUNNINGHAM I TO KNOW
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE CAREFUL WITH HIM.
THAT MEASURE HAS EIGHT WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN. FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM THREE SB [inaudible]
TWO ELEVEN BERMAN.
BERMAN I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
THIS AREA HI NAZARIAN AYE
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT MEASURE HAS
THIRTEEN WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
[inaudible]
TWO SEVEN SEVEN BERMAN.
BERMAN I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
SB [inaudible]
TWO SEVEN SEVEN JEFF.
I DIDN'T RECEIVE THEIR THE THEY
HAVE YOU AS AN AYE -- I HAVEN'T
GOTTEN -- TO YES I HAVE YOU AS
AN EYE ON BOTH THOSE MEASURES
[inaudible]
THERE WAS.
BUT FOR THE BILL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB FOUR
OF FIVE BIGELOW [inaudible]
Q..
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
AM I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN BIGELOW
AYE.
SO WE CAN MOVE BACK INTO.
SELECT COMMITTEE.
HEARING -- SENATOR ALLEN WE HAVE
SB SEVEN FORTY TWO GOOD TO SEE
YOU SIR.
WHAT ARE YOU READY MEMBERS --
I'M SO GLAD YOU'RE EXCITED ABOUT
THIS BILL -- THIS BILL I I SEE
SOME FOR YOU REMOVES
PROHIBITIONS IN CALIFORNIA LAW
WHICH CURRENTLY BANNED -- OUR
INTER CITY RAIL THROUGH A BUSES
FROM SELLING TICKETS TO ANY
PASSENGER UNLESS YOU'RE SHE ARE
THE ROAD ON A TRAIN BEFORE
CATCHING A BUS OR IS RIDING ON A
BUS TO CATCH A TRAIN.
NOW WE'VE HAD SOME PRETTY
EXTENSIVE NEGOTIATIONS LED BY
THIS COMMITTEE AND I WHICH I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE AND WE'VE.
TAKEN SUBSTANTIAL AMENDMENTS
THAT -- HAVE MOVED GREAT
GREYHOUND IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION.
THUS REMOVING ALL KNOWN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL -- SO
THESE WILL HELP MAKE OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM BETTER
HAPPEN GIVE MORE DETAILS BUT
I'VE GOT DâN LEAVITT USE --
MANAGER OF REGIONAL INITIATIVES
FOR THE CHOICE SAN JOAQUIN JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY IN TUCKER FROM
RAIL PACK -- WE'RE BOTH HERE --
TO TO TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PLAYSTATION EMILY
REPRESENTING PLEASE.
DAN LEVITZ I REPRESENT BOTH SO
KEEN JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY IN
THE SUCH BY REAL WORKING GROUP.
AND I'LL JUST KEEP IT SHORT --
WE WE REALLY SUPPORT THIS --
BILL AND SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS.
WITH THIS PLEASE -- DARKROOM
REAL PASSENGERS SO SEE ATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND I ALSO WILL KEEP
IT SHORT.
AND SIMPLY STATE THAT WE ARE
VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THE MOVE TO THE PUBLIC
IN ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THE
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OUT
ROBINSON -- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS ASSOCIATION
AGAIN -- JUST ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE AUTHOR REALLY APPRECIATE
THE STAFF AND AND THAT MISTER
ALLEN'S OFFICE WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL HERE ON WITH CHAU YOUR
IN TWO AND A HALF THE COUNTIES
OF STANISLAUS IN SAN JOAQUIN IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON JIM I ALSO WHAT
THE CAPITAL QUARTER DURING
POWERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM LIGHTS ALSO WITH CAPITAL
QUARTER IN SUPPORT -- STEVE ALL
COMING UP THIS NOVEMBER IN A
REAL TRANSIT DISTRICT AND
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION IN
SUPPORT. TWENTY HUNTER ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE GARCIA
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARC WATTS
REPRESENT GREYHOUND I JUST I
THINK THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND
MELISSA ONE OF YOUR STAFF.
THEIR OUTSTANDING JOB THE RESULT
OF THE JULY FIRST AMENDMENTS
ALLOWED US MOVE FROM OPPOSITION
TO HIS TO NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH PINE
AND WE HAVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BUS ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN NEUTRAL
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF AND
THE AUTHORS OFFICE THANK YOU.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR
SHARE CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS
BILL.
SEEING NONE IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR MR FALL.
A CENTER ICE WHEN APPLIED TO
WORK IN A FIVE MATT IF YOU WOULD --
IF YOU WOULD BE OPEN TO THIS I
REQUEST TO BE CO AUTHORS --
WOULD LOVE THAT THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
YEAH.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YOUR MEMBERS THERE'S A BUS UP
AND ON THE NORTH COAST THAT --
RUNS EVERY DAY UP UP DOWN THE
NORTH COAST AND AND IT IS
TOTALLY UNDER UTILIZED BECAUSE
PEOPLE CAN'T -- THEY CAN'T BOARD
THE BUS AFTER ITS LEFT TRAIN
STATION.
CRAZY SYSTEM IT'S RUNNING HOW WE
HAVE WE HAVE SITUATIONS LIKE
THIS ALL OVER THE OVER THE STATE
WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE GOT --
MORE SEEN SYSTEM IN PLACE AND
FOR THAT AYE AYE.
OTHER THIS BILL AND RESPECT US
RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ONE THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH --
THE COMMITTEE TO FORGE AN
AGREEMENT OF ALL THE STAKE
HOLDERS WERE THINKING WAS WHITE.
COR STAYING ON TOP OF THIS AND
SHE SAW THE IMPORTANCE OF HOW.
THIS COULD COME TOGETHER IN AN
IMPACT.
CAN BE A BENEFIT TO ALL
[inaudible]
ALL PARTIES.
SO LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW
THE THIS CHANGE MAKES OUR INTER
CITY RAIL INNER CITY BUS BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LOCAL TRANSIT.
BETTER INTEGRATED WORKING BETTER
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS -- WE HAVE
A FIRST BY MR GIPSON SECOND BY.
MISTER FONG MA'AM SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ISSUE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM HI DALY AYE DALY AYE
A DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I GRAYSON.
AND I AM MEDINA.
DEAN I IN THIS AREA.
THIS AREA AND I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
THAT IS THIRTY WILL BELIEVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
CENTER MCGUIRE TIMING IS
IMPECCABLE.
SEVERAL BE HEARINGS SB -- THREE
FIVE SIX OTHER PLACES.
YOU TURN RIGHT AT IT THANK YOU
SO MUCH -- BOTTOM LINE AND I
KNOW THAT WE ARE SHORT ON TIME --
THIS BILL WOULD TRANSFER ABOUT A
THREE HUNDRED MILE MOSTLY
ABANDONED RAILWAY TRANSITION OF
FUNCTIONALLY BANKRUPT HUG PUBLIC
AGENCY INTO A TRAIL AGENCY.
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
NEXT STEP IS TO CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS ALONG
WITH YOUR STAFF -- CITY WALK
HERE IN THE OFFICE NUMBER AND
EVERY REAL TRANSIT DISTRICT WERE
WILLING AND ABLE TO TAKE ON THIS --
TASK AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT WE
SHOULD THAT.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THE LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
OFFICE BILL PLEASE TEACH ME MANY
REPRESENTED.
HELLO.
I'M CATHERINE GARCIA ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A LATE COMER
COME ON DONE CURVE HEALDSBURG
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE IS THE
PUBLIC THROUGH LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OR SHARE CONCERNS
WITH THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
HEY THANK YOU SIMILAR VERY MUCH
PREFER THE WORK WITH.
SERVICE LIKE CLOSE OVER MISS
MEDINA AND YOU HAVE A QUESTION --
I'M SORRY I SAW HAND GO.
HELLO FOR MY CENTER WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I DON'T THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THEY CAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU SIR MCGUIRE FOR THIS BILL.
I'M GLAD THE NC ARE A BUSINESS
GETTING SORTED OUT AND
APPRECIATE.
APPRECIATE YOUR DEDICATION THIS
ISSUE.
I HOPE IT GETS RESOLVED AS YOU
DO.
HE SOON.
AND YOUR REGION WILL BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM THESE CHANGES WITH
THAT I'LL SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY MEADOW SURGERY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THINKING.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE [inaudible]
TO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ ARIAN.
JERRY AND I O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL AYE.
THAT HAS.
TWELVE AS WELL WE'VE ROLE
PERHAPS MEMBERS CONGRATULATIONS.
SO WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL --
FOR ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF SHOWN
UP -- SORRY WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND GOING THROUGH -- START ALL
OVER AGAIN AND THANK YOU SO --
WHEELS OF SERGEANTS TO CALL ANY
OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS THAT WE
CAN -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
BUT NO THE RECORD ON LIFTING THE
CALL -- MADAM SECRETARY.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
SYRIAN.
I WAS THERE AND I O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
FOURTEEN AND LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ONE
TWENTY SEVEN BIGELOW
[inaudible]
BIGELOW NO [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
YES.
THE SYRIAN I MEASURE HAS NINE
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM THREE SB TWO ELEVEN
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GRAYSON I GRAYSON I THAT MEASURE
HAS FOURTEEN EYES WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
[inaudible]
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FRIEDMAN
GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE.
MEASURE HAS ELEVEN LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM FIVE SB [inaudible]
THREE FIFTY SIX Q. [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
MEASURE HAS TWELVE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
[inaudible]
FOUR OH FIVE FRIEDMAN.
MEASURE HAS FOURTEEN EYES LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
EIGHT SIX TWENTY FIVE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSONI NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA I THAT MEASURE HAS TEN
EYES WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT EMBERS FILE ITEM ELEVEN
SB SEVEN FORTY TWO CHIU
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
THAT MEASURE HAS THIRTEEN NUYS
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SHE'S COMING RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
YEAH.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
FIFTEEN VOTES IT IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ONE
TWENTY SEVEN FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I THAT MEASURE HAS TEN
VOTES TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
TWO ELEVEN FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I THAT MEASURE HAS
FIFTEEN EYES IT IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I THAT MEASURE HAS
TWELVE VOTES WILL LEAVE IT THE
ROLE OPENED.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE
FIFTY SIX FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I THAT MEASURE HAS
THIRTEEN VOTES WE WILL BE OPEN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB FOUR
OH FIVE FRIEDMAN.
I THAT MEASURE HAS FIFTEEN OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I THAT MEASURE HAS YOU
LEFT AND I WAS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I THAT MEASURE HAS
FOURTEEN EYES WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN
WHO HAD WITH THE CALL.
FILE ITEM FIVE SB THREE FIFTY
SIX CHIU [inaudible]
CHU I THAT MEASURE HAS FOURTEEN
I FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
SEVEN FORTY TWO CHIU.
I THAT MEASURE HAS.
FIFTEEN LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS NOW
COMPLETE WE ARE IN A GERMAN